this month we're going to be looking at
this topic actually it's I think a month
to the day that your first a p20 will be
the 2nd of September I believe which
maybe you're like what already this
thing's been sitting up here and here we
are right now is the second the actual
queue it's not something first
but anyway your job timetable is I think
you actually so it's coming so this
whole month we're gonna be looking at
Donna its Nats sort of the [ __ ] you
study or driving we're going to go
through all of these ideas together so
carefully you'll get the conditions so
collecting data displaying it interpret
data and then lastly the prelim course
anyhow summarizing data now just like we
did with the driving focus that I just
sort of boil it down into some simpler
language so collecting data first your
to get the data
secondly once you've got that data you
want to be able to show it and you also
want to be able to read it if so what
else is showing you Donna right so
that's a display and integrity means
show it in some form in there are lots
and lots of different forms and be able
to read it interpret as well know what
it means
first lastly summarize the data so one
of the tricky things about data is
there's so much in that you want to
distill it down because otherwise it's
just incomprehensible it's like you know
I was just thinking last night about
like what why is it important that we
look at this I've alluded to the fact
that up to unity such a what since they
don't learn any of this which is crazy
good morning which is why actually in
the new services that they're discussing
to launch in two years our bear put
dinosaur sistex into tuna and extension
because they've realized that just like
we give it to you everyone really needs
to learn stuff I thought a three big
reasons why this is like really really
useful number one this happens to me I
couldn't ask event I mean it's have to
see your senses you we've alluded that
before so I think it's actually yeah
it's a week we're a week out from
actually probably your parents will get
open up the big four but Everest do at
the same time on Tuesday oh is it really
yeah teach us to talk about that so well
I don't know if you're gonna be there
when your parents figure out the
question the last time I did it it was a
very it's a fairly long process is a lot
of questions answer so number one it's
timely number two no matter what kind of
job you have in the future like all of
the types of work you'll be doing will
be involved with data in some way like
you've got to understand times and money
and people and all of the ways to sort
of tied it up in an ethos that's is the
way we do that lastly I just wanted to
show you even if your word does it
involve Donna in a big way you are
constantly being presented with Donna
and so you need to be able to understand
like how these like what all of these
things mean so if I pull out things like
this so a few table so these are two
graphs that represent the same Talent
okay we're actually going to look at a
specific some point under I think it's
undies to talk about misleading graphs
now both of these represent the same
Donna knew carefully what's the
difference between them it's the scale
right now the fancy word for this the
fancy phrase which I'll explain what we
get to it it's called a truncated y-axis
okay so have a look at these numbers
right this starts from 0 that's
generally we expect the bottom of the
graph to be and then you go up okay but
graphs frequently don't start from 0
they start from some number which
whoever is giving you the data wants to
choose to make this like convenient to
convey oh my goodness look at the
interest rates but actually the changes
are quite wide you this happens all the
time and sports that's a really bad this
actually because they just want to show
you something and make it look just
thinking like oh wow gee that guy's not
do it so well Missy or three so the
presented can be hugely deceptive right
here's another one this is like a
company right and this picture looks
good right
companies do it okay except again I'm
going to show you the same data but
presented slightly differently this is
the same company and the same numbers
but maybe you're like wait how could one
be going up and won't be going down I
wish you look carefully and I want you
to come back to this one to see what's
the difference okay so one word
cumulative for right so this presents
okay over time Hathi so if I add
everything up
so this graph it has to go up at least
you'd hope right so over time it's
increasing but it kind of masks the fact
that actually over time the company is
do we poorer and poorer losing market
share or whatever it is okay so again
say Donna presented differently um he's
it takes a second to work out what's
going on here right this kind of looks
good it looks like a gun deaths are
decreasing right except they're not why
not the graph is upside down zeros on
the top zeros at the top so effect the
lower this graph goes the more gun
deaths there are and you kind of look at
the way they've tried to try like say oh
yeah this is the red mark it's sneaky
right yeah exactly
this is why it's not like twins quit but
it's sort of was popularized by here
that there are lies damned lies and
statistics is try and you know pull the
wool over your eyes
now I've got a couple okay so wait
presented with data that is what we call
it correlated right so two sets of data
and they seem to be connected in some
way so this is actually a very famous
example so it's like thanks a lot
Nicholas Cage I blame you for all of the
deaths by people performing in touch
but that seat said there is a
correlation loosely but there's no
causation right it's not like one causes
the other
or because cage is like what's a bit
were drowning your pools I should really
make some more films this year this is
not a connection like that at all right
so things like that this is a pretty
important why don't you drive two things
to you here right climate change
yeah there's this incredible culture of
climate change deniers and they'll look
at a graph like this and say okay now
there are two significant problems with
this number one the way I give it as
being drawn that there is really no more
warming is this red line does anyone
know what the red lines called it's got
a special name probably easy especially
it's called a threatened alliance so
it's like we've got lots of them as they
going up and down and up and down but
like what's the overall trend okay so
looks like yeah things are going down
except for the fact that this is
actually not a trend line at all
how have they made this line look
carefully you can tell me how they
weren't that where it goes okay oh yeah
look it's clearly it's cold right oh all
they have done and it's yeah it should
be a line of best fit but it's not
because they've just joined the start
point to the end point just yeah that's
all they've done right now it just
imagined how do I came at this this year
over here if I had started at 99 rather
than 98 the line they would have drawn
would be quite different right it would
have gone from here upwards actually the
trend line or the wider best people on
this should be going up despite the fact
that it starts at a particularly higher
value okay
yeah that's so there's the other problem
yeah I'm not sure if this is gonna be PC
that good morning
let me try this yeah there we go
is that better you can see that okay so
this shows you from going further back
like now you know 298 is just around
here right that's the data they were
looking at but when you look at a longer
trend it's like oh yeah this is this is
looking a little worse and I could go
further back as well and people are
going to argue back and forth okay now
the last one I say the last word to the
best one to last you can just go to the
Donald J Trump approach and tweets up
you like it yeah just how about look at
it just have a look at that first day
you know okay it's not immediately
obvious what the problem is there's
maybe like this one which is kind of
like huh what's going on for starters
what is this list of percentages for one
thing it clearly doesn't have 200
percent right so there's overlapping
numbers that are kind of been compounded
here okay so you're like what what is
this list supposed to represent but you
start to see as you read the words more
carefully you're like oh this blacks and
then this whites and then these
categories that clearly overlap like
just because they're police that doesn't
mean they're not white like what does
that mean okay so it's just confusing
and then more interestingly there's this
picked on the bottom which obviously I'm
not expecting you today but it says the
sources from the crime statistics bureau
in San Francisco the tiny little
following that is there is the crime
statistics bureau one of the issues with
this is that no one knows exactly where
this divers come but no one's been able
to cooperate it so it's almost like it's
just been playing made up I can't know
obviously you look at this you scrolling
through on your feet and of course
you're not going to go inside or one
better
fact check this one right so therefore
statistics this is something which is
just going to be in your life and you
need to go
okay which is why I think it's so cool
so the very first item and you can make
a new sub head if you have already the
very first I will look at the ds1 if
you've got to collect Donald well the
first thing you would do is work out
well how are we going to do this okay so
the subheading is survey design there
are gonna be three kinds of I'm
questions of weight issues that we need
to be aware of if this first one I'm
gonna get you there um in pairs or
whatever I just kind of brace on a few
you guys have filled out surveys before
loads and loads and loads of them
or arcs and surveyed I like it to the
people around you and answer this
question for me just brace up a little
bit what kinds of questions can you ask
or or maybe you know what kinds of
questions have you been asked if this is
all kinds right there's lots of
different types of questions that will
give you different kinds of data so
think about all the surveys you've ever
answer if you get a questions you've
been asked it all the same
okay so let me give you a tip a
multiple-choice question is different to
a question where you have to like
provide a kind of response rather than
select so there you go that's two broad
categories I've already h2 you can I
give you two three minutes to talk to
the people around you well I have a sip
of this lovely looking hot chocolate and
there won't come together with mortis